bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant l'audition de jean
claude ameisen devant la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat jean claude
ameisen et le candidat proposé par
françois hollande pour diriger le comité
consultatif national d'éthique pour les
sciences de la vie et de la santé
le ccn eux alors jean claude ameisen est
un chercheur professeur d'immunologie il
dirige déjà le ccn depuis deux ans et la
mission de ce comité est d'alimenter les
débats sur la bioéthique et les progrès
de la science en faisant participer les
citoyens à ces débats je vous propose
donc tout de suite d'écoutés jean-claude
ami zen devant les sénateurs
donc nous nous réunissons cet après midi
dans cette salle en application de
l'article 13 de la constitution pour
nous prononcer sur la nomination de
monsieur jean claude ameisen à la
présidence du ccn le comité consultatif
national d'éthique pour les sciences de
la vie et de la santé
après avoir procédé à son audition
publique
vous connaissez tous évidemment le rôle
du cce qui permet par ses avis
d'éclairer l'opinion publique et les
autorités politiques sur les questions
d'ordre éthique soulevées par les
progrès de la biologie et de la médecine
le professeur jean claude ameisen a
présidé pendant dix ans le comité
d'éthique de l'inserm et siège depuis
2005 au cce dont il est président depuis
2012 est donc proposé de le reconduire
dans ses fonctions
je vais immédiatement lui céder la
parole afin qu'ils évoquent le bilan
d'activités ccn et de durant ses deux
années de présidence et les perspectives
qui entrevoit pour les années à venir
à la fin de son audition pour le mettre
à la porte
et puis nous posterons au vote
en même temps d'ailleurs que ce
s'effectuera le vote à l'assemblée
nationale mais je vous ai fait ensuite
les conditions dans lesquelles tout ça
doit se faire mais sur professeur
monsieur le président nous vous passons
bien volontiers la parole
merci beaucoup bonjour quelques mots
peut-être sur sur la démarche éthique
puisque vous savez qu'il ya beaucoup
d'approchés de et de représentation de
ce qu'est la démarche éthique pour moi
peut-être en raison de m'en de mon
parcours et et de mon histoire là
la démarche éthique est très proche de
la démarche de recherche
la démarche de recherche en science est
une démarche à la fois de respect pour
l'ensemble du du savoir et des
connaissances accumulées et en même
temps une démarche de transgression qui
fait le pari que remettre en cause les
connaissances actuelles est le meilleur
moyen les questionner le meilleur moyen
de parvenir peut-être à des
connaissances nouvelles demain et donc
je trouve qu'il ya entre la recherche
scientifique et le savoir une relation
qui est assez proche de celle qui entre
la démarche éthique et la déontologie
les lois les les pratiques et que donc
la démarche éthique est à la fois une
démarche de respect pour l'ensemble des
solutions qui a été trouvé pour pouvoir
mettre en relation les pratiques et les
et les valeurs et en même temps une
démarche de questionnement qui vise à
explorer l'inconnu pour essayer de
trouver des des réponses éventuellement
plus satisfaisante ou plus souhaitable
la deuxième relation je dirais entre la
recherche et la démarche éthique tient
au fait que la démarche scientifique en
et façon les frontières entre la matière
inanimée le vivent entre les cellules et
corps entre l'animal et l'humain entre
le corps et l'esprit à quelque chose qui
à la fois et merveilleux
mais qui peut donner l'impression d'une
d'une démarche de déshumanisation d'une
démarche de réification surtout lorsque
ce qu'elle observe et qu'elle étudié
call manipule comme objet vu de
l'extérieur nous concerne directement
parce que ça concerne le vivant parce
que ça concerne des parties de
nous-mêmes ou parce que ça nous concerne
et c'est ce que ce qu'évoquait martin
buber dans un très beau livre jeu et tu
il ya 80 ans disant que la science
lorsqu'elle parle de nous dit il ou elle
ou ceci ou cela et que nous nous vivons
comme des jeux qui disent tu qu'on
attende quiconque on attend des autres
qu'il nous dise tu es que nous
construisons à nous est donc l'enjeu
éthique disette il était de réussir à
mettre ce que nous apprenons de la
science en tant qu sur nous en tant qu'
il elle ceci ou cela au service du jeu
du tu es dunes ou et ya je crois 2 2
deux grands principes de la démarche
éthique biomédicale modernes qui sont
fondés sur cette vision
la première est l'un des piliers depuis
soixante dix ans puisqu'au nuremberg en
1947 de la démarche éthique du médical
moderne qui est ce qu'on appelait le
consentement libre et informé qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le choix libre et
informé qu'ils implicitement définit une
hiérarchie entre la connaissance et
l'autonomie et la liberté cercle a
connaissance dans le temps le côté
informé du choix libre et informé la
connaissance est mise à la disposition
de la personne pour que la personne
puisse élaborer librement son choix
ça n'est pas la personne qui est
instrumentalisée de part la connaissance
qu'on a acquis sur elle par une démarche
scientifique
là la deuxième application c'est le fait
qu'aujourd'hui un comité comme le comité
consultatif national d'éthique n'est
considérez les comme légitime dans le
monde que si les indépendants
et que si il ne comporte pas que des
experts en biologie et en médecine
l'expertisé nécessaire mais elle est
considérée comme insuffisante et donc un
comité qui ne serait constituée que de
biologistes et 2000 ce serait considéré
comme illégitime quand les questions qui
se pose c'est celle du meilleur moyen de
mettre les connaissances scientifiques
en biologie et en médecine au service du
respect de la personne et donc il ya
cette idée de croiser les regards et
d'élaborer une réflexion qui dépasse qui
inclut mais qui dépasse l expertise et
ma conviction profonde en ce qui
concerne le comité consultatif national
d'éthique et que sa mission essentielle
en tout cas mes yeux est de favoriser la
réflexion et l'élaboration individuelles
et collectives d'une forme de choix
libre et informé et non pas de se
substituer à la réflexion et au choix de
la société
quelques mots sur le comité consultatif
national d'éthique que vous connaissez
c'est le premier comité de ce type créée
au monde
il a été créé il ya 31 ans il ya
maintenant des comités consultatifs
nationaux des tic dans tous les pays
européens et dans la plupart des pays du
monde
quarante membres une minorité de
biologistes et de médecins et des
philosophes des juristes des
anthropologues des sociologues 40
membres nommés par une quinzaine
d'institutions ce qui assure à priori
une diversité de parcours et de points
de vue
une mission élaborer des avis depuis 31
ans vit depuis 30 ans depuis la vie
numéro un le comité a élaboré 122 avis
alors avis auquel le législateur nous a
dit que nous pouvons adjoindre si nous
le jugeons utile des recommandations je
reviens à ce que je disais il semble
qu'à mission essentielle c'est d'aider à
la réflexion et on peut éventuellement
lorsque ça semble indispensable
nécessaire y adjoindre des
recommandations mais c'est vrai que dans
les sociétés souvent l'idée c'est que le
comité recommande
d'une certaine façon se substitue à la
réflexion éthique de la société
deuxième mission animer la réflexion et
dont il ya une journée public qui est
qui est conçue par le législateur et ce
dans cette journée nous la consacrons
depuis deux ans à des travaux de lycéens
une douzaine de lycées en partenariat
avec le ccn eux qui pendant l'année sur
la base du volontariat avec leur
professeur de philosophie et de sciences
de la vie et de la terre réfléchissent à
une question éthique viennent la
présenter en public discute avec les
membres du cce et discutent avec le
public et donc je pense que c'est
intéressant là encore 2 j'espère que
cette initiative pourrait être étendue
au-delà de cette douzaine de deux lycées
partenaires parce que je pense que c'est
important que l'appropriation d'une
réflexion éthique commence relativement
tôt si on veut véritablement qu'elles
vivent dans la société et depuis la loi
du 7 juillet 2011 relative à la
bioéthique le législateur a confié une
autre mission au ccn je dirais quirky
qui qui rajoute à cette notion
d'animation du débat public c'est que en
cas de projet de réforme en cas de au
cas où un projet de loi est envisagée le
comité doit initier l'organisation d'un
débat public sous la forme d' états
généraux comportant des conférences de
citoyens durant ces deux dernières
années nous avons rendu quatre avis et
et nous avons été particulièrement
occupé par les questions qui concernent
la fin de vie et nous sommes entrés dans
des activités je voulais décrire
brièvement inhabituel et nouvelle pour
le ccn donc à partir du moment où en
juillet 2012 le président de la
république a nommé la commission sicard
la commission de réflexion sur la fin de
vie il a annoncé qu'une fois que la
commission lui remettra son rapport il
saisirait le ccn eux ce qui l'a fait au
début de l'année 2013 et donc nous avons
rendu un avis la vie 121
sur les questions éthiques liées à la
fin de vie étant donné qu'il y avait eu
annonce du dépôt d'un projet de loi
nous avons dans cet avis recommandez
proposé la tenue d'un débat public et
l'organisation d'une conférence de
citoyens nous avons donc organisé une
conférence de citoyens qui a donc je
pourrais vous parler
si vous le souhaitez qui a rendu son
avis en décembre 2013
et pour donner à ces débats a une
envergure plus proche des états généraux
la commission sicard avait déjà nous en
avons bénéficié organiser des débats
citoyens dans neuf villes de france et
donc nous sommes allés voir les les
responsables de tous les espaces
régionaux de réflexion éthique qui ont
été créés formellement il ya deux ans et
dont une des missions est d'animer les
débats publics sur les questions
d'éthique biomédicale dans leur région
en leur demandant s'ils le souhaitaient
d'animer des débats autour de cette
question de la fin de vie oui à part
droit et donc c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
et huit de ces espaces région de
réflexion éthique nous ont renvoyé les
comptes rendus de ces débats que nous
avons mis en ligne une fois que nous
avons donc l'organisation de cette
conférence de citoyens étaient quelque
chose de totalement nouveau très
inhabituel est extrêmement intéressant
pour le comité consultatif national
d'éthique
nous avons ensuite été impliqué dans une
autre démarche nouvelle et inhabituelle
lorsque le conseil d'état statuant sur
le cas de monsieur vincent lambert a
demandé au ccnr au conseil national de
l'ordre des médecins à l'académie
nationale de médecine et à jean leonetti
de lui fournir des observations écrites
d'ordre général susceptibles de
l'éclairer sur les notions d'obstination
déraisonnable et de maintien artificiel
en vie pour des personnes qui comme sur
un sol en verre sont dans un état dit
pussy relationnel c'est à dire de
conscience minimale et donc ça nous a
amenés à réfléchir à la fois aux
questions éthiques et à l'interprétation
de la loi du 22 avril 2005
à propos de deux situations tout à fait
extrême de conscience minimale et puis
ensuite comme nous le demande la la le
législateur dans la loi du 7 juillet
2011 relative à la bioéthique
nous avons élaboré un rapport sur
l'ensemble du débat public c'est à dire
sur ce qui avait eu en terme de débats
publics depuis la création de la
commission sicard rapport que nous avons
rendu tout récemment durant le mois
d'octobre
donc c'est sais je dirais que la la la
réflexion à propos de la fin de vie sur
les questions éthiques posés par la fin
de vie nous a amenés non seulement à
réfléchir de manière approfondie et
successives
je dirais à mesurer la complexité des
enjeux à mesure que nous progressions
dans notre réflexion mais aussi de le
faire dans un cadre et dans un contexte
et dans des activités qui jusqu'à
maintenant n'a vait pas été celle du ccn
en dehors de ça je vous ai dit nous
avons produit quatre avis donc un sur la
fin de vie
l'autre était sur les questions éthiques
posés par c'était une saisine du
ministère de la ministre de la santé
imposée par l'éventuelle mise sur le
marché de tests de diagnostic rapide de
l'infection par le vih que les personnes
peuvent réaliser elle même le deuxième
c'était une saisine de du directeur
général de la santé c'étaient les
questions éthiques posés par le
séquençage complet de l'adn chez un
foetus âgé de huit semaines à partir
d'une goutte de sang prélevée chez la
femme enceinte dont qui pose toute une
série de deux questions nouvelles et le
troisième liste at her nous avait confié
là encore 2011 une mission de veille sur
les neurosciences sur les questions
éthiques posés par une conscience et
nous avons donc produit un avis sur les
questions éthiques liées à ce que nous
avons intitulé entre guillemets la neuro
améliorations à ce que les anglo-saxons
appellent nioro en une semaine un terme
très ambigu
qui peut être traduit à la fois par noro
augmentation et neuro améliorations
comme si forcément toute amélioration
provenait d'une augmentation des
capacités les sujets sur lesquels nous
sommes en train de travailler
actuellement de manière très brièvement
l'un nous nous étions saisi il ya un an
et demi des questions relatives à
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
est plutôt que de les traiter une par
une
de la manière dont dans ces questions se
posent maintenant assez mination chez
des couples de femmes cryopréservation
des ovocytes pour une fécondation in
vitro ultérieure gestation pour autrui
anonymat pour les donneurs de voix cité
de spermatozoïdes nous avons décidé de
réfléchir d'une manière transversale aux
questions éthiques que pose l'assistance
médicale à la procréation dans l'espoir
de pouvoir ensuite décliné cette grille
d'interprétation aux différentes
situations pour ne pas réfléchir à ces
situations en ordre dispersé et
éventuellement de manière contradictoire
donc d'appliquer un peu la même démarche
que nous avons eues en ce qui concerne
la fin de vie le deuxième sujet sur
lequel nous travaillons c'est
l'extension de de la question du
séquençage de l'adn chez le foetus âgé
de huit semaines
c'est toutes les questions éthiques
liées au séquençage complet de l'adn à
tous les âges de la vie
et puis la troisième question qui est
une question inhabituelle pour le une
habituelle pour le ccn
mais qui progresse est une question qui
concerne ce une autosaisine les
questions éthiques posés par les
atteintes à la biodiversité et les
changements climatiques est donc juste à
ce propos on a souvent l'impression et
c'est vrai que les questions d'éthique
biomédicale portent essentiellement sur
le tout début de la vie l'embryon
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
l'hérédité et la génétique et la toute
fin de vie mais le cce a par le passé
aborder les questions qui sortent de ce
champ par exemple
un avis sur santé et médecine en prison
il ya eu un avis sur angers éthique des
nanosciences et des nanotechnologies a
eu un avis sur enjeux éthiques et
implications éthiques de la biométrie
dans les papiers d'identité donc le le
ccn essaye je dirais de deux d'embrasser
de réfléchir aux questions qui touchent
l'éthique biomédicale qu'il s'agisse
d'avancées récentes de la biologie de la
médecine ou qu'ils s'agissent d'avancer
un peu plus ancien mais qui poserait des
problèmes et des questions éthiques
contemporaine un mot peut-être sur nos
activités internationales
il y à tous les deux ans le dernier
était en juin à mexico il y à tous les
deux ans une réunion de l'ensemble des
comités d'éthique dans le monde
il y a une à deux fois par an le dernier
thé ya deux semaines à rome une réunion
de tous les comités d'éthique de la
communauté européenne et il y a
traditionnellement à cause de deux
raisons historiques des réunions deux
fois par an entre le comité français le
comité allemand et le comité anglais et
donc ces réunions sont extrêmement
utiles parce que je vous ai parlé de
regards croisés à l'intérieur du comité
mais lorsque nous nous réunissons entre
comité de pays différents que ce soit en
europe ou plus forte raison quand il
s'agit du monde
eh bien ces regards croisés sont pas
seulement des lots des regards croisés
de personnes dont les parcours ou les
professions sont différentes mais deux
personnes qui habitent des pays dont
l'histoire la culture est différente et
donc ça nous en méfier énormément et en
général ce que nous percevons céder ce
qui nous apparaît comme des points
aveugles dans les raisonnements de nos
collègues et nos collègues nous font
ressortir que certains de nos
raisonnements et certaines de leurs
réflexions comporte des points aveugles
sur lesquels il est bon ensuite de
pouvoir revenir et de pouvoir nous
réinterroger
un mot peut-être sur un certain nombre
de 2 d'avancé que que je souhaiterais
que nous souhaiterions mené la première
concerne cette dimension internationale
avec peut-être deux objectifs la c on
parle beaucoup dans les débats d'éthique
biomédicale dans notre pays on parle
beaucoup des autres de ce qui se fait
dans d'autres pays y compris dans
d'autres pays européens mais on écoute
assez rarement les autres nous parlait
de ce qu'il pense de ce qui s'y fait
donc faire en sorte que les débats les
débats publics et réflexion puisse
comporter nos homologues des comités
d'éthique d'autres pays pour faciliter
la réflexion dans dans dans notre pays
le deuxième c'est la disparité des
législations dans les différents pays
européens et vous savez que ça pose des
problèmes et récemment encore au niveau
juridique en ce qui concerne la
gestation pour autrui et le statut des
enfants nés par gestation pour autrui
avec la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme qui veille au respect des droits
de la convention européenne des droits
de l'homme est donc une des questions
c'est comment mener une réflexion
éthique
je dirais qu'il prend en compte à la
fois la disparité des législations dans
les différents pays européens
la libre circulation des citoyens à
travers l'europe et le fait que la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et la
cour européenne de justice juge du
caractère du respect des droits
fondamentaux des personnes dans des
législations qui sont très différentes
et parfois même contradictoires et donc
nous avons demandé à nos homologues
il ya trois semaines lors d'une des
réunions que nous avions avec eux
anglais et allemands de réfléchir avec
nous de commencer à réfléchir avec nous
à aa une à la réflexion éthique que l'on
peut avoir un par rapport à à ces
problèmes complexes et je pense que ça
deviendra ça devrait devenir un des
sujets du premier sommet mondial du
prochain sommet mondial qui aura lieu
dans dans un an et demi à berlin
troisième point je vous ai parlé de ce
sujet que nous traitons actuellement qui
est biodiversité questions éthiques
liées à l'aide de dire c'était au climat
nous pensons que c'est une réflexion qui
ne peut pas être une réflexion purement
française parce que les enjeux sont
mondiaux et internationaux et donc nous
voulons avant la conférence climat qui
aura lieu en décembre 2015
organiser un symposium avec nos
homologues de comités d'éthique de pays
étrangers en particulier l'hémisphère
sud pour réfléchir ensemble au moment où
nous essayons d'élaborer un avis aux
questions éthiques
avec ces regards croisés internationaux
qui se posent en matière de biodiversité
et le pari la question c'est est-ce
qu'une réflexion éthique sur ce sujet
apporter quelque chose par rapport aux
réflexions d'experts qui sont déjà
abondantes dans ce domaine le deuxième
fois c'est l'organisation du débat
public je vous disais essayer d'y
introduire un regard international mais
aussi essayer de faire en sorte que le
comité consultatif national d'éthique ne
se retrouvent pas opérateurs de
l'organisation de tous les débats
publics
parce que si nous devenons opérateurs
d'organisation de débat public nous
cesserons de pouvoir assurer nos autres
missions dont publie cette heure très
très très sagement demandé au comité
d'initiés l'organisation d'états
généraux et donc nous sommes en
réflexion et discussion en particulier
avec la commission nationale du débat
public pour voir si d'autres
institutions dont le rôle est d'animer
dans d'autres domaines
la réflexion le débat public peuvent
nous aider à animer une réflexion dans
ce domaine troisième point je vous ai
parlé de cette initiative ancien du ccn
et d'animation de la réflexion éthique
chez les lycéens
nous souhaitons l'étendre aux étudiants
et donc favorisées pour des étudiants
dans des universités la réflexion
éthique et donc on on vient de mettre en
place un partenariat avec l'école
normale supérieure pour commencer et ça
se fera sous forme de symposium organisé
par des étudiants des différentes
disciplines sciences dures sciences
humaines et sociales les enseignants et
des membres du cce pour essayer sur un
certain nombre de sujets transversaux
encore une fois de voir comment on peut
passer de l'animation de la réflexion
éthique au niveau lycéens à une
animation de la réflexion éthique ou à
l'émergence à la facilitation de
l'émergence de réflexion éthique dans le
monde des étudiants voilà merci
voilà mes chers collègues je pense qu'il
y a évidemment beaucoup de questions le
premier cas levé la main c'est monsieur
code francs oui sauf que ça ne vous
surprendra pas jeu il y as en 2012 quand
vous étiez venu devant nous messieurs le
professeur je vous avais posé trois
questions
je vous avais demandé quel était votre
votre schéma de travail sur la fin de
vie
la procréation médicalement assistée la
gpa menée en partie d'y répondre
et donc aujourd'hui qu'en est il je
considère que sur sur la fin de vie
le conseil consultatif national
d'éthique a rempli parfaitement son rôle
ils pourront informer les décideurs que
nous sommes de ce que nous devons mettre
dans une éventuelle loi
vous avez donc rappelé la vie 121
vous avez rappelé la vie que vous voulez
drame de remettre au mois d'octobre qui
est un peu différent beaucoup pas
beaucoup un peu différent il paraît que
ça n'est pas un avis et un rap est une
activité nouvelle du ccn eux c'est à
dire au fond c'est la lecture par le ccn
de ce qui s'est dit ou deux ce qui de
ceux dont nous pensons que ça ne s'est
pas dit mais que c'est aussi interprété
au cours du débat public un rapport
c'était la vie c'était 521 et vous allez
organiser ce débat public avec une
conférence citoyenne qui a fait valoir
un certain nombre de dispositions
qu'elle est peut-être beaucoup plus loin
que ce que certains auraient pu imaginer
notamment sur la fin de vie sur la
possibilité d'accès à un acte médical
pour abréger l'existence est également
sur le suicide assisté
donc les avis que vous avez rendu là
elle rappeur je pense nous permettent d
parfaitement éclairé il appartient
maintenant au législateur ou au
gouvernement de s'en saisir pour déposer
ou pas un texte de loi je considère que
vous avez le cn parfaitement rempli son
son travail en la matière concernant
l'assistance médicalisée à propre
rotation pourriez-vous nous dire dans
quel délai vous envisagez de pouvoir
remettre j'ai pas ici un avis ou un
rapport mais il est évident que depuis
2012 il ya eu des évolutions la loi
taubira et donc la perspective que l'on
peut avoir sur la procréation
médicalement assistée voir la gpa peut
être différente de l'époque
ensuite concernant la gestation pour
autrui même s'il a été déclarée par
beaucoup de personnes que le débat n'ait
pas lieu d'être
force est de constater qu'il s'impose à
nous puisque c'est qu'elle a fait qui
existe et je pense que nous avons une
loi une proposition de loi déposée par
monsieur leonetti qui doit passer à
l'assemblée nationale dans peu de temps
qui est une proposition de loi qui est
purement répressive et qu'il n'ouvre pas
le débat sur la gp11 donc je veux savoir
quand est ce que vous pouvez imaginer de
remettre un avis du cn sur ce sur ce
problème
il serait peut-être urgent d'attendre
avant de légiférer que vous aillez
formuler un avis je voudrais vous dire
aussi que je partage totalement votre
sentiment sur la dimension
internationale parce qu'il est il est
vrai pour les problèmes d'éthique comme
beaucoup d'autres problèmes sociétaux la
libre circulation des individus fait que
nous devons tenir compte de
l'environnement international que nous
pouvons pas prétendre légiférer tout
seul sans tenir compte des incidences
que d'autres pays l'agitation d'autres
pays peuvent avoir et je
le partage parfaitement également votre
avis sur le fait que le conseil
consultatif national d'éthique ne peut
pas être le lieu du débat public sur
tous les sujets il risquerait de perdre
sa fonction donc en conséquence et en
ouverture je considère attend qu'un
petit peu anciens comme doute ici que ce
que nous avions demandé le conseil
consultatif national d'éthique a
parfaitement rempli le rôle que nous les
avions assignés et demandez bien donc
après avoir donné la parole à un ancien
va donner la parole à une jeune modano
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président du comité consultatif national
d'éthique
je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire une
observation puis des remerciements parce
que les questions que j'avais préparé
pour cette rencontre a été justement
basé sur après deux ans de présidence
quel était votre bilan et vous l'avez
tout à fait tracer et puis je voulais
vous demander quelles sont les
perspectives
moi je pensais que effectivement le
comité souffrait d'un certain manque de
visibilité dans le grand public en fait
est clairement vous avez exprimée à
travers vos propos le fait que vous vous
étiez intéressé à des questions
d'actualité qui ont été d'ailleurs
apporté par mon collègue et que donc ça
vous ouvrait des perspectives pour être
mieux connu et puis l'indication sur ces
animations que vous faites auprès des
jeunes me paraît tout à fait aussi
essentiel pour justement pas vulgariser
mais en tout cas vraiment mieux faire
connaître votre avoue est juste une
petite question parce que pendant le
l'examen du plfss nous avons une
question qui a été débattue
au sein de notre commission c'était par
rapport au don du sang et il est
question de médecine et des questions
d'éthique
en fait le don du sang doit-il être
gratuit quand on parle de dont on
pourrait penser que oui en même temps
c'est que dans d'autres pays
voilà c'est quelque chose ce qui est
rémunérée et puis il ya ces produits de
substitution au sang qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous qu'il y avait cette vue
national voire international
donc merci de vos réponses bien mais
pour l'instant nous écoutant le
professeur alors sur la sur la question
de l'assistance médicale à la
procréation alors sur la question de la
gestation pour autrui le comité avait
rendu un avis il ya quatre ans mais
comme vous dites nous nous revenons nous
nous nous examinons l'ensemble des
questions liées à l'assistance médicale
à la procréation et donc la gestation
pour autrui en fait partie je pense
c'est ce que j'avais annoncé que cet
avis ne sera pas rendu public
il avance avant le printemps la fin du
printemps le début de l'été de l'année
2015 pour l'instant étant donné qu'il
n'y a pas eu des annonces de dépôt d'un
projet de loi
nous n'avons pas engagé lalala
l'organisation d'une conférence de
citoyens et des états généraux mais je
dire donc nous travaillons comme si
c'était un avis habituel et donc je
pense que ça sera ça sera le printemps
en ce qui concerne le don du sang
votre question sur le don du sang alors
je peux vous donner mon ma vision
personnelle je pense que c'est un sujet
que le comité va revoir pour le deuxième
aspect de la question vous posiez qui
sont les laits produits et leur libre
circulation y compris lorsqu'il s'agit
de prendre les industriels
vendu est commercialisé avec la libre
circulation à travers l'europe donc je
crois que c'est une question que le
comité va peut-être prendre mais sur le
don de la gratuité du don du sang
à titre personnel je pense que s'ils
voulaient le don du sang contrairement à
d'autres dons est un don fond qui ne
présentent pas de risque pour les
personnes c'est pas comme un don
d'ovocytes c'est pas commun à un don de
rein et donc c'est quelque chose qui
dans beaucoup de pays pour attirer un
plus grand nombre de donneurs eh bien on
m'a dit on va les payer
je crois que le cette idée de la
gratuité du don qui est un pléonasme
comme vous le disiez celedon rémunéré
c'est pas des dons on achète tous les
jours des dons qu'on qu'on paye donc je
crois qu'il faut aussi garder le sens
des mots font un don c'est quelque chose
qui est gratuit et je crois que fonder
le notre système de santé sur la
gratuité des produits biologiques qui
sont mis à disposition de ceux qui
souffrent à un aspect éthique important
qui est que si on paye pour du sandre
mais c'est vrai pour tous les produits
biologiques et bien la probabilité est
grande que ce sont ceux qui sont les
plus démunis qui sont les plus pauvres
qui vont donner et je crois que base et
un système de solidarité en matière de
santé sur la contribution de ceux qui
d'une certaine façon paradoxalement en
ont le plus besoin et y ont le moins
accès pour que d'autres puissent avoir
accès et quelque chose qui pose un
problème éthique et donc pour moi c'est
c'est pas de temps si vous voulez le
risque que du don du sang il n'y a pas
de risque quand le fait raisonnablement
qu'on le paye qu'on ne paye pas après
les demandes sans ça ne change rien mais
je crois que ça fonde une approche de la
santé publique qui je crois est est
particulière et je crois mérite
considération réflexion par rapport à
d'autres pays et on voit que ce qui est
vrai pour le don du sang dans beaucoup
d'autres pays du monde est vrai aussi
pour le prélèvement d'ovocytes puisque
certains de nos voisins européens
après les mots changent rémunère
indemnise lorsque il y as non pas ton
mais lorsqu il y a possibilité de mettre
à disposition des ovocytes et je crois
que c'est ça vraiment le problème il ya
une contradiction il est évident qu'une
incitation financière augmente le nombre
de contributeurs
mais créer une profonde asymétrie entre
ceux qui contribuent et ceux qui
reçoivent dans dans la société
d'autres questions
madame david oui merci monsieur le
président remerciait le professeur à mes
fans et remercier également nos deux
collègues puisque c'est vrai que les
questions étaient intéressantes
notamment sur le don du sang c'est vrai
que nous avons eu un fort débat à la
commission donc c'est bien que nous
puissions en reparler aujourd'hui je
répétais deux précisions à vous demandez
vous nous avez parlé monsieur le
président de possibilité de tout saisine
du comité d'éthique donc par exemple
vous nous avez dit sans doute on va se
saisir du don enfin en tout cas de la
deuxième partie de la question de notre
collègue sur les produits de
substitution
comment est ce que vous pouvez enfin
quelle quelle est la procédure si je
compose terme d'autosaisine enfin je les
imagine un peu mais est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous l'a précisé et comment
faites-vous pour choisir des sujets
justement pour lesquelles le comité
consultatif national d'éthique peut se
saisir
vous avez sans doute vous avez aussi des
demandes qui vous sont transmises mais
comment faites vous pour vous auto
saisir et sur quel sujet puisque vous
nous avez également parlé dans votre
introduction de de votre démarche et du
lien que vous voyez entre ce comité
d'éthique et la recherche puisque vous
nous avez parlé d'une démarche de
questionnement
donc est ce que là aussi vous pouvez
nous nous dira un petit peu comment se
les membres du comité se questionne pour
pouvoir aboutir à cette auto saisine ou
à d'autres sujets et je reviendrai juste
sur ce dont a parlé notre collègue jean
pierre godefroy sur ce qui a été ce que
vous avez organisé des états généraux et
la consultation que vous avez mené avec
l'avis rendu la vie 121 vous vous en
souvenez on s'était rencontré à cette
occasion un moment un peu avant de
mettre en route
ces débats et j'avais été un peu comment
dire je trouve pas un mot comment qui ne
soit pas j'avais été un peu interpellé
on va dire sur le choix des
personnalités que vous aviez choisi pour
pour animer ces débats voilà donc
comment faites vous aussi pour le choix
des personnalités puisque dans cette
consultation des citoyens
c'est donc des femmes et des hommes qui
sont un petit peu choisis et qui est
participent à ces ateliers et qui sont
en contact avec des spécialistes
comment faites vous pour avoir des
spécialistes je dirais non pas neutre
parce qu'un spécialiste n'est pas
forcément neutre mais en tout cas qui
qui a un regard complet sur l'ensemble
du du dossier merci madame procas yonne
merci à monsieur le président monsieur
médecine ce matin nos informations on
entendait qu'il y avait une une
nouvelles possibilités pour les dons
d'organes et en l'occurrence quand une
équipe médicale décide qu'elle va cesser
de faire de prodiguer des soins parce
que il n'y a plus du tout d'espoir
j'aimerais simplement savoir si pour ce
type d'extensions de dons d'organes
le comité a été associée et et comment
vous avez travaillé dans ces cas là pour
aboutir à ce qui est mis en place un
objet dix ans merci monsieur le
professeur je partirai d2 et des
exemples comme que nos collègues ont
évoqué le don d'organes la différence de
l'initiation 3 législation française et
différents pays européens
le sujet de le sujet de la fin de vie et
savoir comment vous intégrer dans vos
travaux la disparité des législations
dans les différents pays et à votre
propre réflexion parce qu'on peut se
dire ah oui mais c'est bien par exemple
je pense au sujet de la fin de vie donc
il fait à peu près enfin j'ai pas dire
complètement mais peut-être à peu près
consensus entre nous on peut se dire bon
d'autres pays sont plus évolués
je pense à d'autres questions par
exemple dont dans le don de le don du
sang on peut on peut peut-être c'est de
recueillir de la position de la position
française
alors comment vous arrivez à consacrer 1
vous intégrez vous concilier les deux
démarches
voilà monsieur professeur c
j'ai reprendre dans l'ordre auto saisine
est saisie d'un certain nombre
d'institutions le président de la
république les ministres voulait donc un
certain nombre d'institutions président
de république l'assemblée par
l'intermédiaire de son président le
sénat les ministères les responsables
dans ces deux institutions de recherche
universitaire peuvent saisir
officiellement le comité consultatif
national d'éthique d'une question
en dehors de ça le comité s'autosaisit
et ils s'auto s'est dit à partir de deux
origines tout citoyen peut écrire toute
association toute profession toute
institution peut écrire au cessé de lui
présenter un problème et lui demander de
s'auto saisir de cette question
à ce moment le cce examine si la
question d'abord lui paraît suffisamment
général nous ne traitons pas de cas
particulier et si la question nous
paraît suffisamment importante par
rapport aux autres questions que nous
devons traiter pour nous en auto saisir
et bien une troisième forme d'auto
saisine qui est lorsque le comité lui
même considère qu'une question que
personne ne lui a posé est suffisamment
importante pour qui la traitent ce qui
donne en général le le cc ne vient que
le croisement des regards le fait qu'il
nous faut élaborer dès le départ un
langage commun une question biologiques
et médicales très pointues et très
complexe à comprendre pour une
philosophe pour un juriste pour une
anthropologue
inversement une question de droit est
très difficile à appréhender pour une
biologiste ou pour un médecin est donc
la première étape c'est déjà d'essayer
de de parler un langage commun
je dirais de rentrer dans une démarche
que qui pourrit coeur était celle de de
l'entrée en éthique qui est de se penser
soi même comme un autre d'essayer de se
mettre à la place des autres
et une fois qu'on a élaboré ce langage
commun on essaye d'avancer dans une
réflexion qui quand elle réussit permet
de faire émerger une réflexion qui est
différente de celle
chacun au départ avait donc nous
confrontons pas des points de vue déjà
pré établis nous essayons de faire
émerger quelque chose qui dépasse les
points de vue initiaux ce qui à mon sens
d'ailleurs et c'est pour ça qu'en quand
je parle d'animation bien public est
quelque chose qui manque beaucoup dans
notre pays house souvent le débat c'est
la confrontation d'opinions préétabli et
pions il faut choisir et c'est pas cette
habitude qui existe dans certains pays
de se mettre à plusieurs dans la
diversité pour essayer de voir si on
peut pas faire émerger faire naître une
réflexion ou une solution nouvelle donc
le le ceas alors le temps est important
pour le ccn de ce qui revient la
première question
nous travaillons bien quand nous
travaillons lentement parce qu'il ya ce
cette acclimatation cette humilité cette
écoute cette construction commune qui
prend du temps qui est un processus au
fond de transformation lorsque nous
sommes saisis avec un calendrier
souhaité nous sommes un peu plus
contraints alors même si nous dépassons
assez souvent le calendrier souhaité
nous essayons de rester dans ce
calendrier
lorsque nous nous auto saucisson c'est
vrai qu'il ya un très grand confort et
donc nous pouvons avancer à la vitesse
que nous croyons être celle de du
service que nous pouvons rendre en voile
est la société donc je pense que le
temps et c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'ils
m'ont beaucoup dans la vie actuelle le
temps de la réflexion
c'est sans doute quelque chose de très
important et soit dit en passant je
pense que les deux ans et demi de temps
consacré au débat et à la réflexion sur
la fin de vie sous des formes très
diverses a sans doute eu un effet sur la
société qui a permis de mieux prendre en
compte les enjeux la complexité là là là
ce questionnement que au tout début donc
qui qui choisit qui décide en premier
lieu il ya douze membres du comité qui
sont élus par les 40 membres
qui constituent ce qu'on appelle la
section technique il ya un président qui
était lui aussi par la section technique
et cette section technique un peu comme
un bureau reçoit les demandes et les
traitent en premier lieu s'interroge
lorsqu'un membre lorsque des membres
souhaitent que le comité s'autosaisit
s'interroge
et puis une fois que cette section
technique a réfléchi elle revient devant
le comité plénier pour voir ce que
pensent l'ensemble des membres et donc
c'est comme ça que collectivement nous
décidons à la fois des questions dont
nous nous saisissons et de la priorité
que nous leur accordons alors nous
pouvons répondre lorsque nous pensons
que il n'y a pas lieu d'élaborer un avis
nous pouvons répondre à ceux qui nous
saisissent sous forme d'une lettre nous
nous expliquons notre point de vue mais
sans 100 ans sans en faire un un avis
alors la conférence de citoyens
conférence de citoyens c'est intéressant
pour nous ça a été tout à fait
intéressant parce que tout à fait
nouveau on a d'abord fait un appel
d'offres public avec un budget limité en
demandant des opérateurs on a eu un
certain nombre d'opérateurs on avait
posé une condition qui a surpris
beaucoup d'opérateurs l'un d'entre nous
avait dit que ce serait impossible ce
qui m'avait beaucoup surpris une des
conditions était que les citoyens ne
soit pas rémunéré et indemnisé mais que
simplement l'offre leurs frais soient
remboursés il semble que de plus en plus
de conférences de citoyens rémunère les
citoyens qui à notre sens n'a pas
vraiment beaucoup de sens puisque ce
sont des personnes qui décident
bénévolement de participer à la
réflexion publique au bénéfice de la
société donc c'était une des conditions
donc l'opérateur que nous avons retenu
était l'ifop l'ifop qui avait d'ailleurs
organisé les trois conférences de
citoyens qui avaient eu lieu
organisée par jean leonetti avant la
révision de la loi relative à la
bioéthique de 2011 une fois que cette
conférence de citoyens étaient réunis
alors les critères choisis il n'était
évidemment pas représentatif de la
population française il faut plus de
1000 personnes
mais il était choisi par l'ifop sur les
critères de l'insee c'est à dire
correspondant en termes d'âge de
profession de répartition géographique
d'habitation rurales ou urbaines à la
grille de l'ensemble de la nation donc
pas représentatif mais c'est à dire
choisis sur des critères qui qui qui
correspondent à ceux de la nation
c'est très intéressant parce que ces 18
personnes se rencontrent pour la
première fois elles ne se connaissent
pas nous avons beaucoup réfléchi pour
savoir si nous voulions assister à leur
réunion parce que c'est très intéressant
de les voir réfléchir et c'est très
intéressant de les écouter discuter
dialoguer avec les personnes qu'elles
s'additionnent et nous avons décidé que
de la même façon que législateur a prévu
que les réunions du comité consultatif
ne sont pas publics mais que c'est le
fruit de ses réflexions qui est rendue
publique
il n'y avait pas de raison de demander à
cette conférence de citoyens de
fonctionner d'une manière qui nous
paraissait pas la plus souhaitable pour
nous et donc nous avons décidé de les
laisser seuls avec un animateur
simplement pour pas de président
animateur pour essayer de dénouer les
moments où où ils risquent de ne rien se
passer et nous leur avons proposé dix
intervenants
enfin ces quatre week-ends dix
intervenants comment est ce que nous
avons choisi le but était évidemment pas
qu'ils soient objectifs le but était qui
reflète au mieux les différents horizons
et les différentes perspectives qu'on
peut avoir sur ces questions de fin de
vie une chose qui a facilité notre choix
c'est que la vie 121 comme un tiers des
avis du ccn avec les habits du ccn ne
sont pas pris à l'unanimité ce qui a
pour effet au cours de la réflexion de
ne pas condamner les membres à être tous
d'accord d'emblée et donc le risque si
on est tous d'accord c'est d'arriver au
plus petit dénominateur commun que ça
soit pas très intéressant donc chacun
participe à la réflexion mais on sait
que si in fine et un ou des membres
pensent qu'il y à une autre façon de
réfléchir ou une autre façon de poser
des questions et bien une opinion
minoritaire et aigris qui est adjointe à
la vie j'ai compté à cette époque est à
peu près un tiers des avis du cce depuis
sa création qui comporte une opinion
minoritaire qui peut être signé par une
personne qui peut être anonyme et qui
peut compter jusqu'à 15 membres du
comité sur 40 mais nous ne comptons pas
donc nous avons un avis majoritaire
nous ne votons pas sauf eux dans le
passé avant que je me prenne la
présidence dans le passé à certains
moments qui était particulièrement
difficile
nous considérons qu'il ya une majorité
et puis que ce qu'ils veulent
éventuellement exprimé une opinion
minoritaire l'expriment il se trouve que
dans la vie 121 il y avait un consensus
sur toute une série de questions qui
concerne l accès aux soins palliatifs
l'accompagnement d'amont là le droit à
une sédation profonde jusqu'au 10 le
fait que les directives anticipées
s'impose aux soignants mais il y avait
une divergence profonde que nous avons
retrouvé d'ailleurs non pas en termes
statistiques mais en termes
d'argumentation dans la société lorsque
nous avons élaboré notre rapport sur la
question d'euthanasie et de l'assistance
au suicide donc l'avis majoritaire
expliquer pour quelles raisons ils
considéraient qu'il n'était pas
souhaitable d'autoriser l'assistance au
suicide et l'euthanasie qui dit très
simplement
c'est le sait le souci d des personnes
les plus vulnérables et la pignon
minoritaires expliquer pourquoi une
autre façon d'aborder la question
permettait d'envisager l'autorisation et
donc nous avions un rapporteur plutôt
deux de l'avis majoritaire et un
rapporteur de la vignery terry donc ce
que j'ai fait c'est que les prix le
rapporteur de l'avis majoritaire et le
rapporteur de l'opinion minoritaires et
nous avons à trois choisit des
intervenants qui reflétait non seulement
ce qui était consensuel mais ces visions
divergentes et donc nous avons eu pour
dire je parle de 10 mais nous avions
jean leonetti est le président de
l'association du droit pour mourir dans
la dignité
donc voilà on a essayé de construire
quelque chose qui soit représentatif des
différentes opinions
nous avons voulu donner une hausse une
dimension internationale et donc j'ai
demandé à deux collègues le président du
comité d'éthique d'un pays qui a la même
législation nous et quelle portugal et
le président du comité d'éthique d'un
pays qui a une situation tout à fait
différent qui est le président du comité
consultatif national d'éthique belgique
de faire partir de ces dix intervenants
pour qu' il est non seulement la
diversité des vues mais une dimension
internationale dans leur réflexion
et puis nous avons fait ce qui se fait
dans d'autres pays c'est pour ne pas
influencer les citoyens nous leur avons
dit qu'une fois qu'il aurait auditionné
ces dix intervenants il pourrait choisir
les dix suivants eux-mêmes et donc ils
ont choisi ils nous ont demandé une
autre en semi leurs demandes pour
demander à dix intervenants
supplémentaire de venir dialoguer avec
eux d'envoyer que le souci c'est de leur
apporter les éléments de la réflexion
mais d'essayer de ne pas les influencer
un en n'insistant pas et de en eux les
formant pas trop je n'aime pas tellement
ce mot de formateurs parce que former
s'est déformée c'est sait comment faire
en sorte qu'ils s'approprient eux mêmes
leurs réflexions en cours de route
et puis lorsqu'ils ont donné leur avis
qui est aussi assez rare je crois
d'après ce que j'ai appris nous avons
décidé parce que souvent les conférences
de citoyens vendent leur avis et puis ce
qui s'est passé d'ailleurs lors de la
révision de la loi de bioéthique de 2011
ce ne sont pas les citoyens qui ont fait
la conférence de presse ce sont les
organisateurs des états généraux qui ont
dit ce que les citoyens pensaient donc
ce que nous avons fait c'est que nous
allons organiser une conférence de
presse dans laquelle les citoyens
rendez compte de leurs avis et les
citoyens dialoguer avec quelques
journalistes
donc c'est vraiment un processus
d'appropriation et je crois que ce qui
nous a beaucoup intéressé c'est je
dirais c'est pas tellement l'opinion et
la vie qu'ils ont émis encore que
l'originalité la façon dont ils y ont
abordé nous a appris des choses c'est
sais je dirais la la le sérieux avait
claqué avec lequel 18 personnes
extrêmement diverses se connaissant pas
s'approprie la réflexion si on leur
donne les moyens au fonds de 2 d'avoir
véritablement une influence et une
action il ya une espèce d'intelligence
collective qui n'est et ses citoyens je
trouve ça très émouvant nous ont dit
lorsqu'on les a rejoint
une fois qu'ils avaient élaboré leur
avis avant la conférence de presse du
lendemain nous ont dit eux que ça les
avait profondément marqué qu'ils
allaient continuer à se revoir et se
sont revus ils ont même j'ai appris
qu'ils ont écrit des articles ensemble
parce que c'est une expérience dont il
nous en dit pour certains le savent et
transformé leur vie
donc je crois que c'est intéressant et
que c'est pas que les conférences de
citoyens soit un moyen privilégié et
bien public mais je crois que ce que ça
nous dit c'est que tous les moyens de
débats publics qui permettent à des
personnes de se réunir dans la diversité
et de croiser leurs regards sont
essentiels indépendamment de tout ce qui
peut exister
je dirais en réunion deux personnes de
même profession de même région et henin
je crois que c'est ça que ça nous
apprend ces riches et c'est intéressant
donc voilà pour la conférence de
citoyens alors j'étais tellement sûre si
vous me rappelez juste
il a conduit la france à la laine
d'accord c'est une profession voilà
j'étais tellement sûr d'avoir compris
que j'ai noté quelque chose qui est
ininterprétable voix la voix la décision
d'aujourd'hui
alors je crois bon le le comité là
encore le comité
le comité de n'a pas travaillé sur cette
question et l'autorisation qui a été
donnée après ce que j'ai appris par l'
agence de la biomédecine aujourd'hui je
dirais tu indépendante pour l'instant
d'un travail du comité le comité a rendu
un certain nombre d'avis sur la question
des greffes d'organes depuis 31 ans est
le dernier avis je crois remonte à à
trois ans mais il n'y a pas eu de
travail spécifique sur cette question je
pense qu'elle mérite là aussi vous voyez
quand je là encore après il ya une
question de priorités de temps et de
possibilités c'est une question qui
mérite d'être posée pourquoi parce que à
mon sens les questions qui se posent
il y en a deux l'une c'est le croisement
entre la loi sur la fin de vie et la
question du don d'organes enfin c'est à
dire si on ne pas arriver un paradoxe ou
au fond la seule raison pour laquelle on
maintiendra en vie une personne que les
traitements ne peuvent pas sauver ce que
la loi du du du 22 avril appelle de
l'obstination déraisonnable serait faite
parce que la justification de
l'obstination déraisonnable
ça serait d'aider autrui et donc comment
est ce qu'on peut penser alors peut-être
que dans le cas d'un consentement
peut-être dans le cadre de directives
anticipées
mais est ce qu'on peut en dehors de
directives anticipées et en dehors d'une
expression d'un souhait croiser de
manière arbitraire
ces deux approches contradictoires donc
ça me paraît une question importante
notre concerne la question
une question à titre personnel qui me
préoccupe depuis un certain temps et qui
le fait que nous accordons en matière de
alors déjà on parle de dons d'organes
une personne qui n'est pas consciente
voir qui est morte cérébralement à ma
connaissance ne donne rien pour donner
il faut veut pouvoir le dire
et donc lorsqu'on parle de dons
d'organes chez des personnes en état de
mort cérébrale c'est assez étrange c'est
comme si la personne se réveillait 10e
donne c'est un prélèvement alors non pas
sauf et c'est là que c'est intéressant
c'est que en france vous avez le droit
de dire non il ya un registre d'une en
est là ce moment on demande à personne
mais vous n'avez pas le droit de dire
oui et d'antoine si vous avez une carte
de donneur ce que beaucoup de gens ont
elle n'a pas de valeur légale et qu'est
ce qu'on va faire on va demander à la
famille si la famille pense que vous ne
vous opposiez pas et donc je crois que
le fait qu'ils aient pas de registre du
oui complique encore cette question vous
voulez poser parce qu'on peut avoir dit
oui avant et pour moi ça existe dans
certains pays il ya toujours une peur
des donneurs d'organes que si on demande
aux gens de dire oui diront pas oui on
peut dire oui on peut dire non et on
peut ne rien dire et si on ne dit rien
il revient à ce moment à la famille ce
qui est un moment très douloureux qui
explique sans doute le nombre de refus
croissant actuellement lorsqu'on demande
aux familles c'est pas des rochers mais
elles disent je ne pense pas que la
personne voulait parce que c'est un peu
bizarre lorsque vous ne dites pas la
personne peut dire oui avant mais on va
demander à la famille si par hasard et
la famille dit si on l'a pas demandé à
la personne pourquoi est ce qu'on nous
demande à nous donc je crois que on peut
dire oui on peut dire non et si on n'a
rien dit à ce moment on laisse à la
famille le soin de dire ce qu'elle pense
que la personne voulait donc je pense
que ces sujets se croiser je pense ça
pose un certain nombre de questions je
ne peux vous communiquer que mon
questionnement personnel à mai mais je
pense que ça mérite une réflexion sous
une forme ou une autre du comité
consultatif national d'éthique alors la
disparité des législations c'est un peu
ce que j'évoquais ce que nous faisons
pour l'instant ce que je souhaite c'est
que nous réfléchissions ensemble entre
comité de pays différents qui sont pas
d'ailleurs forcément en phase avec la
loi
c'est pas parce qu'un comité est dans un
pays dont la législation est telle que
le comité ne questionne pas cette
législation
mais il a l'expérience de cette pratique
que nous voyons du dehors et que que les
membres du comité vous voit de
l'intérieur et donc j'aimerais bien que
nous réfléchissions ensemble y compris
je dirais dans une vision altruiste ma
première préoccupation c est ce qu un
pays qui par exemple prenons
l'angleterre autorisa gestation pour
autrui sous certaines conditions
considérera que le fait que nous
n'autorisons pas bah c'est notre
problème et c'est pas à eux de réfléchir
pour nous aider à penser donc ma
première la première question c'est ce
que nous pouvons réfléchir ensemble
d'une manière altruiste c'est à dire au
fond nous préoccuper du questionnement
des autres même si le problème ne se
pose pas dans le pays que ce soit dans
un sens ou dans l'autre
est ce que nous pouvons aider ceux qui
ceux qui prélève le sang en rémunérant à
réfléchir en nous mettant à leur place
et en les aidant
donc ça c'est ce que je souhaite pour
l'instant ce n'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe pour l'instant ce qui se passe
c'est que nous bénéficions de la
réflexion de nos collègues pour
approfondir la nôtre
et ce qui est intéressant c'est pas
tellement que dans un pays ont dit oui
et dans un autre pays on dîne en c2 quel
point on part pour arriver à cette
conclusion risqué presse jusque et
enrichit énormément la réflexion c'est
de voir qu'il ya plusieurs façon de
poser le problème
indépendamment de la de la conclusion
qu'on en tire est donc ces différentes
façons de poser le problème même si elle
ne change rien aux conclusions ou à une
réflexion je dirais nous enrichissent
c'est à dire qu'au fond nous
réfléchissons nous réfléchissons dans
une meilleure connaissance des causes
que si nous étions seuls à nous poser la
question j'ai trouvé que dans beaucoup
de domaines qu'il s'agisse la fin de vie
du début de vie de beaucoup d'autres
questions
les conclusions qui nous qui peuvent
nous paraître étrange ne sont pas des
coudes dcl
elle procède d'un état d'une réflexion
d'une façon poser les questions de
présupposés qu'on peut d'ailleurs
ensuite discuté qui sont différents des
nôtres et donc c'est ça c'est ça qui
nous enrichit je dirais
depuis depuis longtemps mais ce que je
souhaiterais maintenant c'est que nous
réfléchissions ensemble à nos problèmes
respectifs
il me reste deux questionneur mais je
voudrais juste vous dire avant de se
retrouver soeur que dans le cadre du don
d'organes que rares étaient ou en état
de mort cérébrale le sénat à l'époque
dans le cas de la terre des lois de
bioéthique avait voté un article
autorisant ce prélèvement
même sans le wii et que c'est cet
article a été supprimée par la
civilisation et ensuite je passe la
parole à madame visite chez lee merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur
mécène vous avez présidé le comité
éthique et scientifique de la fondation
internationale de la recherche appliquée
sur le handicap en en même temps je
pense sur les enfants handicapés et je
voulais savoir à peu près si vous pouvez
nous en dire davantage
nous en étions sachant quand même que
tous les anglais entre 800 et 900
enfants qui naissent en france
otis on décèle l'autisme peu de temps
après et surtout on nous dit qu'il est
en gros 70 à 80 % de garçons parmi ces
autistes
merci monsieur amiel wilma questions
posées porté sur la fin de vie et sur
les limites entre l'égalisation et
dépénalisation de l'euthanasie un jeu
prenant carrément le mot alors deux
choses vous avez parlé de des
conférences des conférences de citoyens
qui intègre fin qui répondent en partie
à la question je voulais poser sur la
participation de nos experts en la
matière parce qu'au fond c'est quelque
chose qui concerne le haut qu'on vienne
tout le monde et dont les décisions sont
prises par des experts qui relève du
médical du juridique ou du philosophique
mais la question de dépénaliser ou de
légiférer peut peut-être se poser sur
les questions de fin de vie parce que
quelque chose que l'on aborde rarement
c'est que
les avis qui sont donnés excusez moi je
mets un peu les pieds dans le plat mais
sont donnés par des gens bien portants
moi je vous fais un bon évidemment je
vous fais part de 30,52 d'exercice de la
médecine la demande d'euthanasie active
est rarissime
moi ça m'est arrivé trois fois en 35 ans
et j'ai accompagné de très très nombreux
patients en fin de vie et je m'aperçois
que l'état d'esprit que l'on peut avoir
quand on est disons le au bord du
gouffre n'est pas forcément du tout le
même que celui que l'on avait la même
personne
vingt ans avant en pleine forme et ça
j'ai rarement vu cette cet aspect abordé
dans les différentes personnes
associations groupes qui qui aborde
cette question là et ça me paraît
pourtant tout à fait crucial
lorsqu'on est au bord de la fin de vie
on n'a pas forcément envie de demander
ce qu'on me demandait 20 ans avant je me
rappelle d'un débat qui est complètement
dépassée c'était devait-on dire la
vérité aux patients vous rappeler
c'était avec léon schwartzenberg
ça remonte à un paquet d'années
maintenant c'est complètement dépassés
ce débat là mais on sait que à l'époque
c'était le directeur du monde qui
pourtant participé du même ouvrage à
s'était fâché lorsqu'on lui avait dit
lorsque le le cancérologue lui avait dit
la vérité là c'est un petit peu la même
chose et donc ça rejoint la deuxième
question je voulais poser
y at-il lieu de légiférer absolument
plutôt que deux dépénaliser et
finalement au ccc la fin de la question
et c'est pas du tout la même chose alors
je ne crois pas que ce soit la fin de la
question je vais vous donner un exemple
la suisse à l'ue la suisse a dépénalisé
l'assistance au suicide
l'euthanasie est interdite donc je veux
dire la dépénalisation peut être aussi
sélectif que l'autorisation je crois
qu'elle dit autre chose
ce n'est pas la même chose d'un point de
vue symbolique de dépénaliser ou
d'autoriser
mais ce n'est pas parce que ce n'est pas
la même chose d'un point de vue
symbolique que ce n'est pas aussi
sélectif
donc je crois que c'est c'est une c'est
une autre question complémentaire et on
voit que certains pays ont autorisé
l'assistance au suicide ou l'euthanasie
d'autres l'ont dépénaliser mais que
c'est très sélectif et c'est étrangement
sélectif si on se place dans un contexte
international puisque la suisse a
dépénalisé l'assistance au suicide les
interdits pénalement l'euthanasie la
belgique autorise l'euthanasie mais
interdit l'assistance au suicide
donc c'est l'image miroir de la suisse
pourquoi la hollande autorise
l'euthanasie et l'assistance au suicide
c'est d'ailleurs le seul pays qui
autorisent les deux avec le luxembourg
l'état d'oregon l'état de washington
l'état du vermont et l'état du montana
aux états unis ont autorisé l'assistance
au suicide et interdisent l'euthanasie
tant qu'on voit que même l'avancé dans
ces questions là pour des raisons qui
sont des raisons d' approche de
réflexion de culture d'histoire n'est
pas du tout évidente et on n'est pas du
tout dans dans du tout rien on est dans
dans dans des raisonnements qui prenne
en compte la question d'autonomie
la question des solidarités de la
question du rôle de la médecine dans un
pays comme la hollande
l'assistance au suicide et l'euthanasie
sont la sphère du médecin en suisse
c'est ou dans les états américains celle
affaire d'association et pas des
médecins vous voyez qu'il ya des tas de
questions que ça pose ce que vous disiez
qui est très important nous le
mentionnons en conclut un peu avant la
conclusion de notre rapport nous disons
que les divergences nous nous trouvons
et nous dit on entre apports qu'il ya il
ya toute une série de deux approches
convergent dans le débat en particulier
un constat accablant
je vous rappelle que ce que nous
retenons du débat c'est que 80% de nos
concitoyens n'ont pas accès au
soulagement de la douleur de leurs
souffrances et à l'accompagnement humain
en fin de vie bien que la loi du 9 juin
1999 donne ce droit à tous depuis 15 ans
donc il ya quelque chose que nous
considérons comme dont nous avons dit
que c'est un scandale il ya toute une
série de réflexions qui sont tout à fait
convergentes et si je devais le résumé
je pense intéressant dans nous pensons
et nous avons et nous avons écrit que la
loi santé et la loi adaptation du pays
au vieillissement est sans doute un des
moyens de réussir à pallier à ce défaut
flagrant pourquoi parce que nous pensons
que si on n'arrive pas à accompagner les
personnes en toute fin de vie c'est
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à les
accompagner avant et que donc si on
n'arrive pas à les accompagner avant il
n'est pas étonnant que dans les trois
dernières semaines
on ne trouve pas un moyen miracle pour
le faire et donc nous pensons que c'est
une question d' accompagnement des
personnes âgées malades handicapés
longtemps avant leur fin qui permettrait
d'inscrire le soin le soulagement de la
douleur le soulagement des souffrances
dans une pratique devenue je dirais
habituelles y compris dans les phases
extrême de la fin de vie deux demandes
convergentes le droit à pouvoir dormir
jusqu'au 17
si on le demande que ça ne soit pas le
médecin qui décide c'est qui est un
paradoxe dans la loi du 22 avril 2005
si la personne est inconsciente le
médecin est obligé de faire une sédation
profonde jusqu'au décès parce qu'on ne
sait pas si la personne pourrait
souffrir si la personne est consciente
c'est le médecin qui décide et donc
l'idée c'est que si la personne le
demande
et bien que ça devient un droit c'est ce
que nous avons perçu la deuxième c'est
les directives anticipées que les
directives anticipées s'impose sauf si
le médecin de bonnes raisons de penser
qu'elles ne correspondent pas à l'état
de la personne et donc il faudrait pas
répliqué en ce qui concerne encore une
fois l'euthanasie l'assistance au
suicide divergences au sein du comité
consultatif et divergences dans la
société y compris sur la terminologie ce
qui nous a beaucoup frappé
pour la conférence de citoyens
contrairement à la commission si car
contrairement au ccn de l'euthanasie
c'est de l'assistance au suicide
ce que dit la conférence du citoyen
c'est ce qui compte c'est l'autonomie de
la personne et donc qu'on me donne les
moyens d'interrompre ma vie ou que
quelqu'un le fasse à ma demande
c'est la même chose pour d'autres comme
la commission si car il ya une
différence radicale entre donner les
moyens à quelqu'un de faire quelque
chose et le faire directement d'envoyer
que même sur la terminologie quelle est
la différence
qu'est ce qui est en jeu il n'y a pas
vraiment l'accord est ce que nous
écrivons un peu avant la fin c'est que
il nous semble qu'une partie de ces
divergences vient non seulement de deux
points de départ de perspective
philosophique et qui culturelle
différente chez les personnes mais
qu'elle vient des différents points
d'où les personnes parlent et donc nous
disons que lorsqu'on parle de fin de vie
je crois que nous avons étudié ce
chapitre 2 qui parlons nous quand nous
parlons de la fin de vie on parle de la
fin de vie de personne quand on est bien
portant on parle de la vie de la fin de
vie de soi quand on est bien portant on
parle de la fin de vie de soi quand on
est malade on parle de 2 2 tonnes de sa
propre femme fille quand on va très mal
on parle de la fin de vie de proches on
parle de la fin de vie de personnes
qu'on ne connaît pas on parle de la fin
de vie de personnes qu'on peut assister
si on et soignants ou on est donc tout
au fond c'est un sujet c'est une
question éthique très particulière parce
que contrairement à beaucoup de
questions d'éthique à nous concerne tous
comment parc d'assistance médicale à la
procréation ça concerne certains d'entre
nous donc il ya ce que ça concerne et il
ya les autres
la fin de vie nous concerne tous mais
elle nous concerne à différents moments
de la vie à des titres très différents
et donc cette espèce de je dirais de
confusion implicite fait que certaines
positions s'opposent
parce qu'on ne parle pas de la fin de
vie des mêmes personnes où on ne parle
pas de sa fin de vie au même stade donc
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
important ce que ce que ce que vous ce
que vous mentionnez et qui nous a paru
un des points je dirais qu'il n'a pas
été questionné ou qui a très peu été
questionnée durant le débat et c'est
pour ça que nous soulevons puisqu'il ya
toute une partie de notre apport que
nous consacrons à essayer de dégager les
questions que nous considérons comme
sous jacente est implicite et dont nous
pensons que la formulation aiderait à
clarifier un certain nombre de points
dans le débat sur ce que vous dites
aussi tout autre chose
il ya un article qui m'avait beaucoup
frappé qui a été fait par steven laureys
ce qui est le directeur du centre du
coma du coma center de liège celui où
vincent lambert avait été examinée au
départ il ya un des deux plus grands
centres du monde d'études des personnes
qui ne sont pas capables de communiquer
en état de conscience minimale
cet article avait été publié en 2011
dans un journal médical john of
neurology et c'était une étude très
particulière 2700 soignants de
l'ensemble des pays du conseil de
l'europe avait reçu un questionnaire
dans ce questionnaire des pleins de
questions
au début les questions concernaient le
fait de savoir si ces soignants si ces
professionnels de santé est ce que si
l'un de leurs patients étaient en état
de conscience minimale
il considérait qu'il fallait arrêter les
traitements l'hydratation et la
nutrition artificielle 70% des soignants
dizaine ont beaucoup plus loin dans le
questionnaire il y avait une question
qui disait si vous étiez dans un état de
conscience minimale est ce que vous
souhaiteriez que on interrompre les
traitements hydratation et nutrition
artificielle 70% des soignants répondait
oui
et l'éditorial de civils auraient
c'était que c'est quand même un problème
éthique si des soignants n'arrive pas ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure soi même
comme un autre aaa a essayé de se mettre
à la place des autres et de réfléchir en
prenant les devants content d'envoyer
comme c'est difficile y compris pour des
soignants qui voient leur fin de vie et
la fin de vie de leurs patients d'une
manière radicalement différente donc je
crois que se mettre ensemble ce que je
disais pour pouvoir réfléchir ensemble
en partant de points de vue différents
mais qui sont explicités
si les traits sans doute l'avancement de
ceux de ce débat sur la fin de vie voilà
vous avez donc pu suivre l'audition de
jean claude ameisen devant la commission
des affaires sociales tout de suite vous
retrouvez preuve par 3 l'émission
politique de public sénat